that's a more honest message than the
simping and pandering that I see today
that oh men will still date single
mothers you could still get remarried
and all this stuff yes you can and it
can happen but you're really shooting
yourself in the foot and we need to stop
putting single motherhood on a pedestal
we need to stop putting these women out
of pedestal that we should praise them
when single mother homes contribute to
every problem in society emotional men
are a problem it leads to homeless men
it leads to men with mental disorders it
leads to men that go to prison it leads
to men that commit suicide every problem
that you can look at in society really
is linked to single mother homes it is
not linked to single father homes